your job obviously here at the
legislature is to ensure that our
freedom of expression is maintained that
our First Amendment rights are
maintained and what that means first and
foremost in my experiences on college
campuses is that the hecklers veto must
be stopped so I was at Cal State Los
Angeles in February 2016 and there was
almost a riot there and the police were
not allowed to do their jobs and
students were physically assaulted in
the crowd it is the job of this
legislature to ensure the police can do
their jobs and when they do do their
jobs and they're allowed to do that a
places like UC Berkeley everything goes
fine and I'd like to make a point here
about UC Berkeley the reason it cost
$600,000 to bring me to UC Berkeley was
not because of me okay everybody keeps
suggesting that it was because I was
coming I'm so controversial and so
terrible I came exactly one year before
and it costed this many dollars it cost
zero dollars for security at UC Berkeley
the reason it cost $600,000 at UC
Berkeley is because an Tifa and violent
groups had decided that Berkeley was
their domain and they were going to be
able to run roughshod over law
enforcement there and this does bring up
one final point that I want to make in
the long period of time that I have to
discuss and that is the problem with a
legislative body such as yours trying to
draw a line specifically about what hate
speech constitutes because the fact is
that one of the reasons groups like
antiva show up is not because they know
who I am it's because they have been
told by people that I am promulgating
hate speech which is utterly false and
utterly untrue there are people who say
vile things and with him I disagree
among them people like milo gianopolous
who sent me a picture of a black baby on
the day of my child's birth because I
wasn't sufficiently standing up for the
white population supposedly but that
does not mean that the legislature gets
to decide what hate speech is I've been
labeled a promulgator of hate speech
when I was the number one target of hate
speech according to the ADL among the
journalistic community in 2016 so let me
suggest that as a legislature your chief
job is to ensure that my taxpayer
dollars in this state go toward making
sure that people like me and people with
whom I disagree get to speak in places
like college campuses and not toward
regulating what speech you find good and
what speech you find bad because it's a
really dangerous business and their
speech I don't like if their speech you
don't like but if we can't agree that
there is a difference between speech and
violence we're not going to be able to
have a free state let alone a free
country thanks